[Música]
un nuevo ataque ruso con misiles mata 11
personas en la ciudad ucraniana de crio
Y al menos otras 28 están heridas por
otro lado Ucrania asegura que ya ha
retomado siete localidades en el oeste
de doniaesca desde el inicio de la
contraofensiva
en Reino Unido aparecieron los cuerpos
de tres personas muertas en las calles
de nottingham en el centro de Inglaterra
y otras tres personas están en el
hospital Después de ser atropelladas por
una furgoneta la policía arrestó a un
sospechoso Tenemos reporte de nuestra
corresponsal
expectativa en Estados Unidos Donald
Trump comparece hoy ante un tribunal
Federal en Miami el ex mandatario
enfrenta cargos por el mal manejo de los
documentos clasificados que fueron
hallados en su residencia en Florida la
policía espera protestas en el lugar de
la audiencia
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarlos
abrimos esta edición con información de
la guerra en Ucrania porque varios
edificios Fueron golpeados por un misil
Ruso antes del amanecer de este martes
en la ciudad de crio y Rock esto es en
el centro de Ucrania el ataque causó al
menos 11 muertos y decenas de heridos
según el último balance previamente kiev
anunció la reconquista de siete pueblos
en el marco de su contraofensiva esto
endoniesk es que oficialmente la
contraofensiva inició este sábado además
se habla de avances acerca de backmud y
torresc movilización a la que Moscú
resta importancia en informes llama al
bentman
la ciudad es ucranianas siguen bajo
ataque durante la noche un asalto con
misiles rusos golpeó la ciudad de
greenboyrock en el centro del país un
edificio Residencial fue alcanzado
ha ocurrido una tragedia en la ciudad
varios cohetes cayeron destruyendo
instalaciones industriales algunas
estructuras y viviendas tras horas de
emergencia todavía hay víctimas bajo los
escombros según las autoridades
ucranianas
estábamos durmiendo todas las ventanas
fueron destrozadas aún no entiendo cómo
ocurrió todo al principio hubo un fuerte
estruendo los coches se incendiaron la
ventana de aquí saltó por los aires fue
terrible
Mientras tanto en el terreno de los
combates el ejército ucraniano Afirma
estar avanzando y recuperando
territorios como estos soldados
celebrando la reconquista del pueblo de
macaríptica donde aún persisten algunos
enfrentamientos
desde el sábado cuando fue el anuncio
oficial de la contraofensiva ucraniana 7
aldeas habrían sido reconquistadas según
kiev un éxito para el presidente
bologylensky
agradezco a nuestros soldados por cada
bandera ucraniana que ahora está
volviendo a su lugar legítimo en los
pueblos del territorio recientemente
liberado
por su parte Moscú considera que la
contraofensiva de kiev ha sido un
fracaso hasta el momento las tropas
rusas mostraron la toma de tanques
leopard donados por Alemania como prueba
de ello y el Ministerio de defensa de
Rusia afirmó que sus tropas han repelido
los avances ucranianos en las regiones
de donets y saporicha
cambiamos de información vamos ahora al
Reino Unido donde la policía británica
anunció el hallazgo esta madrugada de
tres cadáveres en las calles de
nottingham en el centro de Inglaterra y
minutos más tarde tres personas fueron
atropelladas por una furgoneta
conectamos ahora para ampliar esta
información con nuestra corresponsal en
la capital británica Luisa Pulido Luisa
Buenas tardes para usted que se sabe de
estos hechos
no se tiene todavía mayores detalles la
policía no ha entregado una nueva
actualización sobre esta cadena de
hechos trágicos que estarían
relacionados entre sí lo que se acaba de
conocer Es que la policía está
trabajando en conjunto con la policía
antiterrorismo y se ha dicho que
mantiene la mente abierta sobre los
posibles hechos y las causas que rodean
este Trágica cadena de hechos la policía
antiterrorismo es lo último allanó una
vivienda en la misma calle donde dos
personas fueron acuchilladas y cuyos
cuerpos fueron encontrados sobre las
cuatro de la mañana otra persona como lo
mencionabas fue hallada muerta también
en magdalajara Road mientras tres
personas resultaron heridas que
permanecen siendo atendidas en un
hospital luego de que una camioneta
intentará atropellarlas por este hecho
por la sospecha de homicidio Fue
capturado un hombre de 31 años que
continúa bajo custodia
la policía la jefe de la policía de
noche De esta zona de nottingham Kate
Miller dijo que este es un hecho
horrible y trágico y reitero que en este
momento la el centro de nottingham una
ciudad pequeña de Inglaterra se
encuentra completamente acordonado
fuerte presencia policial policías que
están tratando de recolectar todas las
pruebas para esclarecer qué es lo que ha
sucedido Luisa Pues mientras estamos
pendientes de esta investigación hay
otra investigación que inicia hoy en el
Reino Unido y tiene que ver con el
manejo por parte de las autoridades de
la pandemia de covid-19 las familiares
de las víctimas piden justicia no
sí que se haga justicia que se
esclarezca qué fue lo que sucedió si el
Reino Unido estaba el gobierno del Reino
Unido manejó la pandemia del Coby 19 de
la manera adecuada recordemos que este
país registró uno de los récords más
altos en el mundo en muertes por este
covid 19 ha iniciado Entonces esta
investigación que puede tardar hasta
tres años para esclarecer para
establecer Cuáles cuáles son las
lecciones que deben ser aprendidas de
aquí en adelante y que puede costar
millones y millones de libras esterlinas
tiene la primera etapa de seis semanas
en las que se escucharán testimonios de
las víctimas especialmente de momentos
muy trágicos porque recordemos que este
país vivió uno de los confinamientos más
largos y más duros y justamente hoy se
rindió un tributo a las víctimas del
cobi 19 se inició esta comparecencia
esta investigación con un video de 17
minutos en el que las familiares de
víctimas rindieron homenaje a sus
familiares que tuvieron que morir
solenos en un hospital porque por las
fuertes condiciones del confinamiento no
pudieron despedirlos Así que es una
investigación que para muchos además de
pedir justicia genera esperanzas Porque
será la oportunidad para hacer una
vigilancia de qué y cuáles fueron las
decisiones Y si fueron especialmente
adecuadas las que tomó el gobierno del
ex Primer Ministro Johnson Pizza pues
muchísimas gracias por este reporte
desde Londres nosotros pasamos a Miami
Estados Unidos donde Este martes el
expresidente Donald Trump será imputado
por la retención ilegal de documentos
clasificados cuando abandonó la casa
blanca y sus seguidores ya han asegurado
que lo van a apoyar ante cualquier
escenario por lo que la alcaldía teme
protestas violentas y reforzó la
seguridad de la ciudad Alba Santana nos
amplía
con la llegada de Donald Trump a Miami
Florida donde se enfrentará a una
audiencia en la que les eran imputados
37 cargos por la retención ilegal de
documentos clasificados cientos de
fanáticos lo esperan frente a uno de sus
hoteles
Y es que la popularidad de Trump y el
partido republicano ha ido en aumento en
el estado antiguamente bastión de los
demócratas en especial a cada vez más
latinos lo apoyan y comparan la
situación del expresidente con la de
algunos opositores en Latinoamérica es
el odio que tiene izquierda y el
comunismo que está ingresando a nuestro
país y quieren introducirnos quitando la
libertad de expresión y no lo vamos a
tolerar las pruebas presentadas por la
fiscalía no parecen suficientes para
ellos y algunos han amenazado con
recurrir a la violencia algo que ya ha
pasado en el país solo me arrodillo por
mi salvador me pondré en pie y moriré no
me importa no me importa algo que ha
hecho saltar las alarmas de la ciudad
que asegura estar preparada para las
protestas
en nuestra ciudad obviamente creemos en
la Constitución y creemos que las
personas deben tener derecho a
expresarse pero también creemos en la
ley y el orden y lo sabemos Esperamos
que este martes sea Pacífico alentamos a
las personas para que mantengan la calma
demostrando lo que sienten y vamos a
tener las fuerzas adecuadas necesarias
para asegurar eso
Y es que una vez más el discurso
incendiario de Trump que mantiene su
inocencia y Define los cargos en su
contra como una caza de brujas podrían
generar violencia a la ciudad sus
seguidores han asegurado planean
apoyarlo durante todo el proceso
continuamos en Estados Unidos donde 10
personas resultaron heridas en un
tiroteo en el centro de Denver Colorado
esta madrugada el ataque se registró
después de que los fanáticos del
baloncesto salieran a las calles para
celebrar que los Denver nuggets ganaron
su primer campeonato de la NBA la
policía dijo que un sospechoso que
estaba entre los heridos fue detenido
tres personas permanecen en estado
crítico en el hospital y el tiroteo se
debió a un altercado y ocurrió
Aproximadamente a 1,6 kilómetros de la
arena donde los nuggets derrotaron a los
Miami Heat
a continuación más noticias en 34
el volcán kilauea en la Isla Grande de
Hawái permanece activo después de entrar
en erupción el miércoles ubicado en un
parque nacional en la Isla Grande de
Hawaii es uno de los volcanes más
activos del mundo este año entró en
erupción por última vez en enero y la
actividad se extendió hasta marzo
en Filipinas el volcán mayon comenzó a
arrojar lava el domingo ubicado en la
provincia de albai es un enorme
atractivo turístico sin embargo las
autoridades elevaron el nivel de alerta
a tres en una escala de 5 por su
potencial explosivo además empezó un
plan de evacuación de unas 14.000
personas que viven a un radio de 6 km
India y Pakistán intensifican los
preparativos antes de que un fuerte
ciclón toque tierra este jueves
clasificado como una tormenta ciclónica
muy severa se espera que biparjoy llegue
a la provincia India de guyarat y
karachi en el sur de Pakistán los
meteorólogos predicen vientos máximos
sostenidos de 135 kilómetros por hora
y a principios de esta semana la capital
de Sudán jartum se vio sometida de nuevo
a intensos ataques aéreos de artillería
y disparos es que tras terminar el
último alto del fuego que duró 24 horas
este fin de semana Los mortíferos a
combates entre las dos facciones
militares enfrentadas se reanudaron
las calles de jartum yacen vacías y
desoladas y los residentes permanecen
encerrados en sus casas mientras
prosigue la batalla entre el ejército y
los paramilitares de las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido tras finalizar El breve
respiro que supuso el alto el fuego de
este fin de semana Los bombardeos y
mortíferos combates se reiniciaron en
las afueras de la capital sudanesa la
ciudad de ondurmand fue objeto de
ataques importantes nada se salvó como
la fachada de esta casa dañada por los
bombardeos
Cómo puede vivir la gente en una ciudad
bombardeada
golpeada y con francotiradores en las
calles
no hay tiendas ni servicios ni mercados
el acuerdo de alto del fuego permitió a
los civiles de la capital comprar
alimentos y medicinas pero con las
reservas que se agotan los residentes
luchan por encontrar suministros
esenciales
los servicios de emergencia tampoco son
accesibles y según la Cruz Roja solo el
20% de los hospitales siguen funcionando
ya han pasado casi dos meses y la
situación humanitaria Es muy difícil
pero ese día hasta faltan suministros
alimentos medicinas incluso para los
heridos y lesionados no hay posibilidad
de ayudarles el conflicto estalló el 15
de abril
desplazando a casi 2 millones de
personas Al menos 450 mil han buscadores
refugio en países vecinos como Egipto la
ONU Calcula que los combates han dejado
a 25 millones de personas es decir la
mitad de la población de Sudán en busca
de ayuda humanitaria
y la ONU anunció que Avanza en la
operación de salvamento del sso safer el
petrolero anclado en las costas de yemen
que no recibe mantenimiento desde 2015 y
que representa una amenaza
medioambiental
avanzan las labores de salvamento que
Naciones Unidas emprendió en el
petrolero foo safer
las autoridades recalcaron que la
contratación de un seguro para operación
es un paso fundamental para continuar la
tarea
estamos en una carrera contrarreloj Así
que insto a los dirigentes de los
gobiernos a los directores generales de
las empresas y a cualquier persona que
esté en condiciones de contribuir que
den un paso al frente y nos apoyen para
que continúe esta operación que está
alcanzando rápidamente una fase crítica
esta embarcación contiene 1,14 millones
de barriles de crudo y el deterioro de
su estructura por la falta de
mantenimiento ausentes desde el
estallido al conflicto en 2015 la han
transformado en una grave amenaza
ambiental y hay alertas de que podría
quebrarse o explotar En caso de que eso
sucediera el seifer amarrado en las
costas de yemen desde 1988 podría vertir
cuatro veces más de petróleo en el mar
rojo que el desastre del éxon Valdés de
1989 en Alaska considerado de los más
graves en el rubro además pone a 200.000
medios de vida en peligro 17 millones de
personas se verían afectadas por las
consecuencias y costaría aproximadamente
20.000 millones de dólares limpiar el
derrame hasta aquí las noticias sigan
con nosotros
[Música]